comment ça va regardez regardez regardez
regardez on se parle de ça on se parle
de la microsoft écrit si noir sur blanc
c'est la surface laptop co2 je vous
avais parlé de la surface laptop go 1 il
ya quelques mois c'était en même bien
presque deux ans était en 2020 et
aujourd'hui je vous parle de la surface
laptop co2 alors la surface laptop co2
tout midi tout mini toutes mes lire
regarder le format il est juste tout
petit et ça c'est hyper canon pourquoi
parce que on peut le prendre le
transporter on peut l'emmener partout
avec soi ça c'est super cool alors
format j'avais beaucoup je vous avait
déjà présenté la surface laptop guen
vous dit à quelques années il ya deux
ans exactement j'avais beaucoup aimé
pourquoi compacité praticité légèreté
vous la mettez dans un sac vous
l'emmenez en 2 go home 2 go comme on dit
donc ça c'est cool et je continue à
trouver c'est ridicule de dire on joue
comme ça je continue à trouver ce format
hyper canouhard pour autant il ya eu des
changements par rapport à la génération
précédente qui n'a pas eu des masses il
y en a eu un peu à commencer par une
baisse de prix oui une baisse de prix et
ça aujourd'hui c'est plutôt rare que les
prix baissent donc on va regarder ça on
va faire un petit tour de cette surface
laptop go on va regarder de tous les
côtés si elle est intéressante celle est
fait pour vous et puis on va regarder
tout ce qui se passe au niveau du prix
moyen avec deux caméras ou stream5
schizophrénique mais c'est pratique on y
va c'est parti maintenant
[Musique]
la surface laptop co2 cl petit écran
tout mignon on va regarder ça dans
quelques instants petit clavier petit
format regardez vous avait pas de places
de perdues pour les haut parleurs d'un
côté comme de l'autre c'est extrêmement
compact et très minimaliste c'est plutôt
bien fichu donc ça c'est déjà très très
chouette elle fait quoi un kilo 127 très
légère mais une fois de plus tout à
retenir ici c'est la finesse du truc
c'est extrêmement fins dont vous voyez
ça c'est tout petit on peut même
l'utiliser comme un ventilateur ça
ferait un ordinateur très cher donc on
ne fait pas mais on pourrait tout en
sachant que vous avez ici trois couleurs
plus une nouvelle couleur la nouvelle
couleur je les passais la verso ge alors
à l'existant platine en verseau jean
bleu glacier ansade la jolie je connais
pas tous par coeur la partie supérieure
ici c'est de l'aluminium et le reste que
vous allez avoir sur le dessous ça c'est
du polymère un petit polymère vous avez
là ce soit un lieu c'est mignon ça mange
bien et permet de descendre un peu les
coûts et ça fait le taff vraiment ici un
écran de 12,4 pousse alors ici c'est pas
du full hd on est sur une résolution
1536 par 1024 pixels à 148 pixels par
pouce exactement la même chose qu'on
avait sur la génération d'avant on est
sur un ratio 3 demie un peu plus long
que le 16/9 on a des haut parleurs
stéréo qui sont planqués quelque part
ici mais qu'on ne voit pas ou par leur
très discret et surtout vous avez un son
qui est quand même alors pas extrêmement
large s'arrête médium ça reste up veut
étouffer mais on laissera un ordi pas
très cher donne à fond voyez sur fond
bon ça fait le taff même si c'est pas
non plus bien révolutionnaire ici on a
néanmoins du bluetooth 5.0 si vous
voulez venir vous appéré directement
avec un casque sans fil côté performance
est là où c'est intéressant ils ont un
regret idée on est sur un i5 vous n'avez
qu'un i 5 ici vous n'avez pas 2007 vous
n'avez pas du tout 2009 vous avez
uniquement un i5 et c'est de la onzième
génération pas de la deuxième génération
sépare mais tirer les cours vers le bas
alors vous allez voir on va parler des
usages en quelques instants on
s'attendre à pas avoir une machine
extrêmement performante on pourra pas
faire des trucs de dingue on pourra pas
faire de montage vidéo un peu costaud
mais on peut faire plein de choses et
surtout un tarif hyper canon il faut
savoir quand même qu'ici vous avez 4 ou
8 gigas de ram c'est de la lpddr2 4x et
128 ou 256 go de stockage en ssd et côté
graphique on aura une intel iris x ray
standard mais c'est normal la batterie
c'est une 41 ou acteurs on de charge de
39 soit ça ne change pas du tout par
rapport à ce qu'on avait sur la première
génération fatalement l'oas il aura
changé on est ici sur un windows 11
alors windows ont j'en ai déjà parlé il
ya plein de nouvelles choses on va avoir
un côté un peu plus entré on va avoir
plein de nouveaux trucs je vous invite à
venir voir la vidéo sur windows os si
vous n'avez toujours pas vu plein de
nouvelles fonctionnalités hyper sexy une
fois de plus je vous renvoie à ma vidéo
le clavier est très sympa très agréable
avec un bon retour de touche le bouton
de démarrage ici à 14 d'empreintes
digitales pour déverrouiller très
rapidement en gros on a tout ce qu'il
nous faut directement sous la main et
les finitions sont vraiment bien par
contre on a un petit trackpad alors ici
c'est pas du tout de la boutique on a un
vrai bouton physique vraiment on
pourrait reprocher qu'ils soient pas
assez grand malgré tout ils vont quand
même une bonne place est ce qu'on pourra
l'élargir un petit peu oui et non c'est
déjà ce que je vous disais lorsque vous
présentez est la première version dans
l'ensemble comme il est là malgré tout
le combo trackpad + clavier mois il va
très bien on va retrouver une petite
caméra située juste là à la regarder
juste ici qui est planqué alors ici
c'est une caméra hd ici pas de full hd
bon alors ce que je vois là déjà je sais
pas si ça va déjà un peu mieux parce que
je trouvais très très très jeune comme
ça lorsque je me mettais là alors c'est
pas une résolution dingue c'est pas une
caméra de dingue elle fera le taf et
pour venir l'utiliser pour venir à
parader comme je suis jeune au nom de
dieu c'est très bizarre parce que là je
suis à 6500 kelvin sais pas si ça vous
parlera mais là je suis je sais pas
c'est un peu change en bons pour venir
faire de la visio en tout cas ça
fonctionnera côté connectique on
retrouve un port surface connect pour
venir la recharge est très facilement et
sans galères et de l'usb de l'usbc et
une prise jack pour bien branché un
casque très facilement alors on pourrait
se dire ok ok ok j'ai effectivement un
usbco news béa c'est pas énorme venez
acheter un petit dock en plus si vous
voulez venir chez par amour à mettre des
photos vous avez pris avec un appareil
photo si vous voulez bien branché
d'autres appareils vous pourrez très
facilement et ça rendra service alors
bien évidemment ici on va voir quoi on
va voir du wifi 600 plus pour sa plus
qu'on trouvait avant et c'est vrai que
l'on va retrouver un ordinateur qui
fonctionne bien qui ne permettra pas
faire des trucs de dingue mais ce qui
fait il le fera bien et c'est tout ce
qu'on attend de lui avant qu'on parle
des usages voudrais qu'on parle des
tarifs déjà je vais vous montrer les
tarifs de l'année dernière alors il ya
un vrai changement par rapport à l'année
dernière l'année dernière vous aviez
trois configurations vous aviez une
version 4 + 64 giga de stockage vous
étiez à 629 euros vous aviez une version
8 +128 et vous étiez à 799 euros
d'ailleurs quand je vous dis l'année
dernière fait pas et dernière c'est en
2020 donc ça il ya deux ans et vous
aviez enfin une autre version 8 + 2 156
et vous étiez à 999 euros ok ça c'est
les tarifs de la surface laptop go 1 là
on parle bien de la deux sauf
qu'aujourd'hui le prix d'entrée le
premier prix se situe à 669 euros
669 euros alors on pourrait dire à elle
commence à aller un peu plus cher en
fait non pas du tout pourquoi ai-je
avait violé contre ça et je suis content
d'ailleurs je pense pas que ce soit que
moi que microsoft ait coûté en tout cas
ils ont vraiment fait vous aviez ici du
64 giga de stockage et on est et on y
lit et mmc on n'était pas du tout un ssd
ce n'est pas du tout une config que je
vous recommandais se trouvait pas du
tout intéressante il disait ça on n'y va
pas déjà c'est trop petit c'est du mmc
ok on laisse tomber on plus de sa 4
gigas de ram c'est pas terrible alors
aujourd'hui regarder et c'est là que ça
devient intéressant on va remettre tous
en perspective alors vous avez bien une
version 4 +128 donc là on se parle bien
de ssd et là on est à 669 euros on est
effectivement un peu plus cher que la
version avec le yémen c'est un peu
pourri mais bon ok ça reste quand même
vachement cohérent et c'est très bien on
a surtout la version 8 +128 on n'est pas
à 799 non on est à 769 ça veut dire
qu'ici waouh j'écris sur ma table le
tarif a baissé à l'élite dont je peux le
faire partir ainsi foutu bon et la
version 8 + 2 156 on n'est pas à 999
quasiment à 1000 euros on est à
869 euros et ça c'est vachement cool ça
change tout ça veut dire que on est
descendu de mille balles pour une config
alors on est sur une nouvelle génération
au niveau d'une telle corps on est sûr
de la 11ème partir de la dixième
génération bon ok ok et je vous le remet
la halle à leucate plus 128,4 +128 et je
dis qu'on était à combien la à 669 euros
alors moi il ya vraiment cette config la
4 gigas de ram je vous le recommande pas
dans un pc aujourd'hui vraiment pas
pourquoi parce que c'est pas terrible ça
va ramer dans le temps vous allez
galères et vous allez vous arracher les
cheveux 8 gigas de ram c'est un très
grand minimum sur l'ordinateur et ça
servira surtout pour tous qui va être
bureautique visionnage de série et
compagnie tous les usages combat à bord
avec son ordinateur et on les détails
dans quelques instants maintenant vous
avez une vraie question à venir vous
poser c'est le stockage 128,2 156 je
recommande toujours en apprendre un peu
plus alors attention il ya quand même
ici un débat de 100 euros bien que votre
128 go de stockage en plus vous et payé
100 balles de plus ce que je vous
recommande la conflit qui est
intéressante celle là 828 à 769 euros
769 euros vous avez une machine qui
tient la route vous avez suffisamment de
stockage et justement ça nous emmène sur
les usages les usages on se dira ce truc
vous allez sur quoi vous êtes forcément
sur un usage en bureautique j'écris
toujours aussi mal dont vous allez venir
travailler ça va être pour des étudiants
ça va être pour j'en sais rien moi des
commerciaux qui vont venir se déplacer
c'est vraiment pour venir travail
travail à la maison prend des notes
travail est ok c'est très simple
bureautique email compagnie ci et ça
dans la bureautique je vais exclure un
peu la navigation sur internet parce que
même si elle en fait partie et bien il
ya un côté un peu sympa lorsqu'on
prépare ses vacances un accoutrement et
normatif que la bureautique bon c'est un
peu dans la même grande famille après
vous allez avoir du divertissement alors
attention par divertissement ce que
j'entends diverti ce moment ce n'est pas
du tout du divertissement qui va être
liés aux jeux vidéo si vous voulez jouer
c'est dans le cloud cloud gaming pas
moins pas plus divertissement ça va être
filmé série netflix 10 n'est plus prête
video by cada les compagnies là vous
l'aurez très bien sans aucun problème
voilà les usa ce qu'on va voir ici donc
ça 8 gigas de ram ça suffit et ça fait
le taf il n'y a pas besoin d'en mettre
plus si on voulait aller faire du
montage vidéo si vous voulez aller
travailler du photoshop multicartes si
on voulait aller plus loin il faudrait
quand même dire booste un peu plus la
machine augmenter la ram passé sur un
grand minimum de 16 giga de ram ce qui
s'il n'est pas possible ici c'est un i5
ses 8 gigas de ram c'est ce que je vous
recommande la vraie question bien vous
posez c'est est-ce que je veux 128 est
ce que je veux de 156 je prends 128,6 je
stocke pas beaucoup de fichiers si j'ai
beaucoup de choses dans le clown ça peut
être j'en sais rien un pack office et
compagnie ça tient la route si bien y'a
pas de souci maintenant vous stockez
beaucoup de choses en interne tout 156 x
y note mais pour moi son ordinateur son
vrai prix 7 769 euros et à 769 euros
vous avez une proto qui est hyper calme
donc voilà ce que je voulais vous
montrer ce que je voulais vous dire je
trouve que une fois de plus c'est un
truc qui est très bien parce que en fait
si vous voulez ça vient ajouter un
produit un tarif hyper canon dans la
gamme de microsoft c'est un petit
ordinateur soit pour débuter soit on n'a
pas besoin d'eux pour os configuration
et surtout qu'on a besoin d'eux pour
l'emmener facilement avec soi qu'un truc
très léger très cool donc effectivement
va pas avoir les meilleures finitions à
l'arrière on n'est pas sûr de la lutte
tous les côtés mais on a un truc qui
marche plutôt bien qu'ils aient plutôt
soyeux on a un clavier
qualité on a un bon track pack on a un
écran même si on n'est pas sur lui full
hd pour garder un peu de contenu
multimédia ça va fonctionner attention
la plupart du temps on craque sur nos
smartphones donc ça fonctionnera pas de
souci là-dessus tribout positionnement
ici de la part de microsoft dont je
trouve très cool a vous de me dire vous
comment vous le trouvez ce que vous avez
acheté la surface tape taupe gohin est
ce que dans le cas contraire vous
pourriez acheter la 2è ce qu'elle vous
tente ce qu'elle vous fait de l'oeil est
ce que vous comprenez le positionnement
pour marquer tout ça juste en bas dans
les commentaires et nous se retrouve
très vite pour continuer à parler de
tête parce que même l'été et l'ordre
moral et peut-être pas en été mais tout
au long de l'année voilà ça comme ça il
ya beaucoup de choses qui se passent
beaucoup et ça c'est bien plus embrasse
prenez soin de vous et à bientôt
l'épisode lamouroux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]